CANDIDATE 1: OK.
I'm looking for a trendy
girl with a simple smile.
BREE: Dating by VHS-- this
is what technology assisted
dating looked like
before the internet.
But who are the people
who actually met this way?
STEVE LIDDICK: I
don't go to bars.
I'm not a church person.
Where else do you go?
So this was the
perfect opportunity
to meet people in a
comfortable, safe atmosphere.
BREE: Steve and Sherry
Liddick are two early adopters
of dating technology.
SHERRY LIDDICK: I was a
year out from a divorce.
And then when I was
suddenly single.
How do I do this?
BREE: Yeah.
Steve and Sherry
met back in 1978
through a video dating service
called "Great Expectations".
They've been married
for 37 years.
STEVE LIDDICK: I
happened to see over
the shoulder of some guy who
was watching a video tape--
this really pretty girl.
And she was the right age
and the right everything.
BREE: It was sort of like
the analog version of online
dating.
Paying members would
go into an office
and look through a
binder full of profiles.
If you saw someone you liked,
you'd watch their interview
on a VHS tape.
Hi, my name is Bree.
And some of my interests
include roller disco, squirrels,
and Ronald Reagan-- no crazies,
no lazies, must love daisies.
What did your friends
and your family
think about you guys using
a video dating service?
STEVE LIDDICK: Loser.
BREE: Really?
STEVE LIDDICK:
What kind of loser
would go to a video
dating service?
SHERRY LIDDICK: Yeah.
They thought it was
a little strange.
BREE: Video daters had a
bad reputation lasting well
into the age of YouTube, when
leaked videos like this one
became viral.
PHIL: My name is Phil.
Most of my friends
called me Big Phil.
CANDIDATE 2: I'm
looking for the goddess.
Are you the goddess?
BREE: What do the two of you
think about online dating?
SHERRY LIDDICK: There
are an awful lot
of people that don't have good
intentions on those sites,
I'm sure.
But there might be
that one that works.
BREE: Did you
think, at the time,
that technology would
become what it is today
and that it would help us
find relationships easier?
STEVE LIDDICK: I
don't think we were
able to think beyond video tape.
Well, look at the different
media that are available now.
We could not even
have imagined that.
BREE: So, while I'm
browsing people on Tinder,
I can think about you guys being
the OG-- the original pioneers
of video dating.
STEVE LIDDICK: Well, the
thing about technology
is, it's there.
We have to deal with it.
If you were traveling from
New York to Los Angeles,
would you go in a covered wagon?
That's the same theory
I have for dating.
You use the technology
that's available now.
CANDIDATE 3: I'm really
looking for somebody
I can feel special about.
And I don't encounter
people like that very often.
I'm hoping you're one of them.
BREE: Hey.
Want to check out
more of my videos?
Head to the nuclear family
channel for some sketch comedy
gold like this video.
WOMAN: I, state your name--
MAN: I will fill that in later.
WOMAN: Hereby present
this certificate
to acknowledge that I
value our relationship
to the tune of $10,000.
BREE: Thanks for watching.
And be sure to subscribe
to "Secret Stories".